what we need to see is inflation coming
down
in a clear and convincing way i think
that bringing inflation down should be
our number one priority the story of
inflation is changing
a year ago wall street a lot of policy
makers in washington were hoping that
the inflation uptick would be what they
call transitory there was a decent
amount of evidence to support that view
that it would be temporary or transitory
that it would come and go away well
that's not what happened to understand
where inflation is spreading in the
average american's household budget we
looked to the labor department's
inflation metric the consumer price
index we came away with some surprises
and some lessons to tell us how the
story of inflation is changing the
inflation we're currently experiencing
began as pandemic lockdown restrictions
were lifted triggering a boom in demand
when inflation turned up in 2021 it was
a different kind of inflation than what
we're seeing right now there were really
two facets to it one was we saw these
idiosyncratic changes for instance used
car prices jumped up in part because
there were shortages of new cars supply
chain bottlenecks and chip shortages
pushed up prices for goods like cars
both new and old and then the other
thing that we saw was prices for other
goods uh jumping up during the pandemic
people
binged on goods they couldn't go out to
restaurants they couldn't go to hotels
and so they ordered amazon and
the spending picked up on a lot of goods
and then as the pandemic receded a
little bit we we had these supply
shortages for imported goods in
particular so you saw things like
furniture prices go up apparel prices
shoe prices stuff that used to be really
cheap because we were importing it from
low-cost labor places was all of a
sudden popping up
but the inflation we've seen recently in
2022 is more severe and more
wide-reaching now we're seeing prices
for services like one of my favorite
indicators is haircuts for 20 years the
price of a haircut was going up between
zero and four percent in this latest
stage they've gone up uh five percent
because the cost of labor is going up
some of the most noticeable recent price
hikes have been at the grocery store
thirteen percent of the average
americans household budget goes to food
and since last april household food
prices are up almost eleven 11
grocery prices were pretty tame actually
last year and what we've seen this year
is increases at double digit levels
since last year prices for ground beef
have risen almost 15 percent and prices
for chicken breasts are up 16.4
so meat is a very interesting case when
you're building a herd
uh this year you're building it for two
or three years out you have to have some
view of what the world is going to look
like in a couple of years cows don't
grow overnight right in 2020
when some of these herds were being
built we were going into a devastating
recession now two years later we're
dealing with with meat shortages because
there's this under supply of meat
meanwhile a combination of factors
caused gas prices to soar
the russia's invasion of ukraine earlier
this year jolted the global market
prompting oil price increases russia's
invasion of ukraine has taken things
like gasoline prices from a stage where
they were recovering from the pandemic
to where they're much higher than they
were before in late may gasoline prices
topped four dollars a gallon in all 50
states for the first time ever currently
california leads the country with prices
over six dollars the war on ukraine has
had a big impact on on global energy
markets when coveted hit
we hit went into this global downturn
the price of gasoline in the u.s went
from around three dollars a gallon to
two dollars a gallon in 2021 but by
early 22 it was back up to over three
dollars a gallon so there was a recovery
we had been through a full cycle then
russia invaded ukraine
and now we have gasoline prices over
five dollars a gallon in many places
higher energy prices have also bled into
air travel analysts say that rising fuel
costs and staffing shortages have led to
a spike in airfares in april airline
fares surged 18.6 from a month earlier
the fastest rise on record americans are
really frustrated right now with what's
happening and one great place to see
that is in what's happening at the
airport flights are being canceled at
the same time that airfares are going up
we also found that the biggest budget
item for most households the cost of
keeping a roof over your head is heading
up housing makes up 30 of the average
household's budget and it's up 5 from a
year ago so rents are another facet of
this inflation problem it relates to
under supply of housing that was built
really over the last 10 years since the
2008 financial crisis and led to less
building
for over a decade and now we're paying a
price for that because we're seeing
price increases
for homes
and that's feeding through into rental
prices we now are entering a period of
transition
from one of historic recovery to one
that can be marked by stable and steady
growth
making this shift is a central piece of
the president's plan to get inflation
under control
without sacrificing the economic gains
we've made as the country heads into the
midterm election season much of the
political discussion is centered around
the damaging impact of inflation a
meeting with chairman today and
secretary yellen
to discuss my top priority and that is
addressing inflation the fed has shifted
its strategy over the last few months
what they're trying to do now and what
they think they have to do is hit the
demand side of the economy and they're
going to do that by raising interest
rates to make it more expensive to
borrow the fed is trying to hit demand
to slow growth economic growth just
enough
so that inflation comes down to more
manageable levels of around two percent
a year so one risk is that they don't
hit demand enough
and inflation remains elevated the other
thing that could go wrong is that they
hit demand so hard that not only do they
bring down inflation
but they drive the whole economy into
recession and in that scenario the real
risk that people need to worry about is
that in the process of going into a
recession they kill this great job
market and unemployment starts rising
[Music]